[Musica]
lo so che vorreste che vi parlassi di
miracoli ma i miracoli sono eventi che
non rispettano le leggi della fisica e
io sono un fisico ok Un astrofisico per
cui Ditemi voi come potrei parlarvi di
miracoli
d'altronde cosa c'è di incredibile nel
fatto che noi umani così piccoli siamo
stati in grado di comprendere ad esempio
che l'universo di cui facciamo parte ha
un'età di 13,6 miliardi di anni
e che è un universo in continua
espansione e in continuo movimento tanto
che in questa mezz'ora iniziale di
spettacolo mentre voi siete qua
comodamente seduti Al Duse e io ero
dietro le quinte con la tremarella Ecco
in questi 30 minuti senza nemmeno
accorgersene abbiamo percorso tutti
insieme quasi mezzo milione di
chilometri attorno al centro della
galassia
parliamo di cose pratiche di qualcosa
che non ci basta mai il tempo
sono sicuro che non sia la prima cosa a
cui pensate quando siete di fretta e
l'autobus è in ritardo ma dovete sapere
che il tempo e la misurazione del tempo
sono profondamente legati ai fenomeni
celesti
quando vado nelle scuole primarie a
parlare di astronomia rompo il ghiaccio
con una domanda molto semplice quanti
anni avete e dopo che mi hanno risposto
con il numero del caso sei sette dieci
la domanda successiva è Cosa vuol dire
che avete 6 7 10 anni e a questo punto i
cucciolini cosa mi dicono abbiamo
compiuto sei volte gli anni abbiamo
fatto la festa soffiato sulle candeline
è aperto i regali
Ok Poi però aggiungono qualcosa di
quantitativo provano a dire di quanto
sono cresciuti ma non c'è un numero che
possa mettere tutti d'accordo
alla fine la risposta sulla quale siamo
tutti d'accordo è che si dice che hanno
6 anni perché da quando sono nati La
Terra ha compiuto sei volte il giro
intorno al sole
e la terra non gira solamente intorno al
sole ma gira anche su se stessa La
conseguenza di questa rotazione è il
moto del sole nel cielo che vediamo ad
esempio in questo timelapse del Sole di
Mezzanotte al Polo Nord
E questa rotazione ci fornisce un metodo
molto utile molto comodo per misurare il
tempo la durata del giorno
Se ci pensate per lunghezze e masse
ancora convivono centimetri e pollici
chilogrammi e Libre e dolce ma per la
misurazione del tempo da sempre tutti i
popoli si sono serviti di un unico
riferimento di un'unica unità di misura
il giorno e le sue frazioni
E allora Quanto dura un secondo la prima
definizione deriva proprio dalla durata
del giorno il giorno è diviso in 24 ore
ogni ore diviso 60 minuti ogni minuto in
60 secondi per un totale di 86.400
fettine tutte uguali ciascuna delle
quali prende il nome di un secondo
Questa è stata la definizione ufficiale
del secondo fino al 1967 una definizione
anche abbastanza semplice da intuire ma
con una pecca non è una definizione
stabile e costante perché la rotazione
della Terra non è poi così regolare
varia anche se di poco
impercettibilmente ma varia e quindi non
possiamo basare su questa quantità
variabile una quantità che dovrebbe
essere costante e così i fisici si sono
dovuti servire di qualcos'altro per
definire secondo e di cosa si sono
serviti si sono serviti della luce la
luce è composta di onde
elettromagnetiche
possiamo pensare alle onde
elettromagnetiche come alle impronte
digitali degli elementi di cui è
composta la natura ogni elemento emette
alcune onde elettromagnetiche che ci
permettono di riconoscerlo
Questo ad esempio è il metodo che
abbiamo usato per scoprire Di cosa sono
fatte le stelle abbiamo riconosciuto
nella luce delle stelle le impronte
digitali di idrogeno Elio e altri gas
E così anche sulla terra se abbiamo a
che fare con un certo elemento sappiamo
esattamente a che frequenza vibrerà la
sua impronta digitale facciamo un
esempio
prendiamo il Cesio il Cesio è un metallo
argenteo duttile non particolarmente
Comune ma nemmeno troppo raro e il Cesio
emette la sua impronta digitale ha una
frequenza di 9 miliardi 192.000 e passa
vibrazioni in un secondo
Ovviamente non è un esempio scelto a
caso vi ho fatto l'esempio sul quale si
sono basati i fisici nel 1967 per dare
la nuova definizione della durata di un
secondo
E questa definizione Vale tuttora e
quindi è una buona definizione anzitutto
è una definizione stabile perché questo
numero è fissato una volta per tutte
è una definizione che è tutto sommato
semplice da riprodurre in un laboratorio
e su questa definizione si basano gli
orologi alsio e un orologio al Cesio è
così stabile che in un intero anno può
sbagliare al massimo di un milionesimo
di secondo quello che noi chiamiamo un
micro secondo
quando io chiamo i miei figli perché
vengono da apparecchiare la tavola e mi
rispondono arriviamo tra un micro
secondo Io di solito mi preoccupo Cioè
so che non sarà un'attesa breve
Eppure un micro secondo è veramente un
intervallo molto breve
per darvi un'idea un microsecondo è
100.000 volte più breve di un battito di
ciglia
ed è 3000 volte più breve del minuscolo
vantaggio con il quale Marcel Jacobs si
è aggiudicato la medaglia d'oro ai
mondiali di atletica indoor quest'anno
brava
ma in fisica un secondo e un micro
secondo non sono cose da poco
anzitutto perché il tempo non è soltanto
il tempo misurare il tempo equivale a
misurare lo spazio
Questo è il principio su cui si basano
ad esempio I GPS e i radar degli
aeroporti
si misura il tempo di andata e ritorno
di un segnale radio fra un riferimento
ed un oggetto E da questo tempo si
determina la posizione dell'oggetto
Attenzione però perché
i segnali radio viaggiano molto
velocemente e se sbagliassimo questa
misura anche soltanto di un microsecondo
sbaglieremo la localizzazione
dell'oggetto di 150 metri Pensate cosa
potrebbe voler dire per esempio per un
aereo in fase di atterraggio
e la sicurezza e la accuratezza della
misura del tempo è importante anche in
altri ambiti ad esempio per la sicurezza
delle transazioni finanziarie
e quindi per tutti questi motivi i
fisici stanno cercando di rispondere
alla domanda Quanto dura un secondo in
modo ancora più preciso ma Sempre
mantenendo questa caratteristica di
stabilità e riproducibilità
e per soddisfare queste caratteristiche
di stabilità e riproducibilità è
fondamentale poter confrontare orologi
che siano in laboratorio distanti fra di
loro e per fare questo è arrivato il
momento di tornare ad fare lo sguardo al
cielo
Questa è la prima immagine di un buco
nero e di questa immagine si è parlato
proprio qui a Bologna in un bellissimo
Ted X pochi anni fa
e questa è la seconda immagine di un
buco nero è l'immagine del buco nero al
centro della nostra galassia quello
attorno al quale ci stiamo muovendo così
velocemente Ecco Queste sono le uniche
due immagini di buchi neri che l'umanità
abbia mai ottenuto
Questa invece sono immagini di Quasar i
Quasar sono sorgenti molto luminose al
centro di galassie molto distanti
e Cosa hanno in comune queste immagini
quelle dei buchi neri e quelle dei
Quasar hanno in comune il fatto di
essere stati ottenute con radiotelescopi
grandi migliaia di chilometri
ora qualcuno di voi forse ricorderà
goldenhay il film di 007 in cui Pierce
Brosnan e renazione nella grande
parabola di recessivo che con i suoi 300
metri di diametro era la parabola più
grande del mondo a quel tempo allora 300
metri migliaia di chilometri ma dai cioè
Va bene Pizza Miracle ma cerchiamo di
non esagerare
E invece sì è possibile ottenere un
radiotelescopio grande migliaia di
chilometri unendo parabole più piccole
purché siano molto distanti e molto ben
sincronizzate fra loro
quanto distanti Beh Ad esempio la
distanza che c'è fra il nostro orario il
telescopio qui a Medicina in provincia
di Bologna e il Giappone oltre 9.000 km
e quanto ben sincronizzati
allora ogni radiotelescopio Deve essere
collegato ad un orologio e nessuno degli
orologi della rete può sbagliare
rispetto agli altri nemmeno di un
millesimo di microsecondo quello che noi
fisici chiamiamo un nano secondo
gli orologi attuali non sono ancora così
buoni e infatti capita di doverli
rimettere al passo durante
L'osservazione Ma i nuovi orologi quelli
che i fisici stanno testando per
definire in modo più preciso il secondo
dovrebbero permetterci di mantenere la
stabilità dell'immagine dei Quasar per
tempi di osservazione molto lunghi di
fatto questo è proprio uno dei test
fondamentali che ogni nuovo metodo di
misurazione del tempo dovrà superare
dovrà essere in grado di mantenere la
stabilità di un'immagine di un Quasar
ottenuta con una rete di Radio telescopi
molto distanti e per tempi molto lunghi
c'è un che di ironico e mi avrebbe da
dire di miracoloso nel fatto che tramite
L'osservazione di questi Quasar possiamo
tenere questa sincronizzazione perché
questo significa avere una
sincronizzazione a livello del
nanosecondo con immagini vecchie milioni
di anni
Sì perché vi ricordate che il tempo non
è soltanto il tempo e quindi quando noi
diciamo che osserviamo un Quasar che si
trova a 100 milioni di anni luce Questo
significa che la luce Ha impiegato 100
milioni di anni per percorrere lo spazio
Fra il Quasar e i nostri telescopi E
allora i nostri telescopi vedono il
Quasar com'era 100 milioni di anni fa
quando qui sulla Terra ancora c'erano i
dinosauri
E allora Quanto dura un secondo molto
poco nulla verrebbe da dire rispetto a
queste scale temporali così immense e
spaventose centinaia di milioni di anni
Eppure l'universo non smette di stupirci
negli ultimi anni abbiamo scoperto che
anche nella vita di una stella un
secondo può rappresentare un intervallo
di tempo molto significativo
pensate che una delle nostre ultime
scoperte è quella dei lampi radio
fenomeni che durano appena un millesimo
di secondo
sono esplosioni che avvengono in campi
magnetici molto intensi che circondano
stelle molto dense e compatte
questa esplosioni viaggiano attraverso
lo spazio intergalattico per centinaia
di milioni di anni e quando ci
raggiungono portano impressa una flebile
traccia di tutto quello che è il
materiale che hanno incontrato nel corso
del loro viaggio
ora con pochi lampi ancora non possiamo
fare tantissimo ma ne Stiamo scoprendo
ogni giorno di più Ogni giorno di nuovi
letteralmente in tutte le direzioni del
cielo e quindi a breve saremo in grado
di fare una scansione dell'intero cielo
e sapere esattamente in ogni direzione
quanto materiale c'è
e sapete di quanto tempo avremo bisogno
abbiamo stimato che sommando la durata
di ciascuno dei lampi che andremo ad
utilizzare si potrà bastare un secondo
e quindi Quanto dura un secondo quanto
basta per pesare l'intero universo
E allora il tempo non è soltanto il
tempo
misurare il tempo equivale a misurare la
distanza e misurare il tempo equivale a
stimare la massa Ok C'è un equivalenza
fra tempo e massa e qua è 10-11 minuti
che vi sto parlando io sento la
pressione qua di tonnellate di materia
oscura che che comprimono quindi vengono
a conclusione
la domanda Quanto dura un secondo e
ancora una domanda aperta e sta tenendo
impegnati fisici e astronomi di tutto il
mondo e mentre noi fisici ed astronomi
ci dedichiamo questa domanda cosa Vorrei
che faceste voi
anzitutto vorrei che vi rimanesse questa
idea di una profonda connessione fra la
tecnologia più sofisticata che abbiamo
qui sulla Terra e quello che accade
nelle sconfinate scale dell'universo
e insieme a questo vorrei che ogni volta
che ammirerete
il cielo di notte e vi sentirete persi
sotto tante stelle come dice una
bellissima canzone
continuate a domandarvi cosa siamo
venuti a fare e che cos'è l'amore che
anche per me astronomo rimane il
miracolo più grande di tutti grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]